Think back to this was meeting six.
It's about the rise of the
Joint Stock Corporation and
the Joint Stock Corporation is without
doubt the most important institution in
the world economy today.
It's only rival might be
states or governments,
but it is just a
massively important thing.
And the question of how it got here and
why it takes the form it does is our
topic today. Let's begin with Adam
Smith. Oh, we've got projection.
I'm going to just talk for a while anyway.
Uh,
begin with which somebody would one of
you guys go up there and get that on
slide one slide show and I'll
rejoin it when we get there.
Um,
Adam Smith in talking about the invisible
hand is also at lengths to say that
the productive use of the division of
Labor kicks in only when you get big
markets only where market scale justifies
and elaborate division of labor and a
large investment of capital.
Do you get the benefits of capitalism
really in tiny markets where you're making
a, for example, clothing for
others in a village of a thousand,
the possibility of a sophisticated
manufacturing scheme,
which,
okay, we're almost there. Here we go.
It's really embarrassing to be
a clutch in front of this night.
Paypal,
somebody who knows his stuff,
please do this navigator.
Yeah.
Get it into navigator.
And then on the slide one and
play slide show and we're set. Um,
so Smith talks about scaled markets and
the great limitation on scaled markets,
uh,
until the early 18 hundreds was the
poor quality of land transportation.
Uh, ocean transportation had by
that time gotten pretty good. Uh,
sailing ships had gotten better and better
in the three or 400 years before 1800
and steam ships. Thank you
so much. Uh, and steam ships,
uh,
had improved that,
but
I'm going to skip some slides.
Uh,
but the great interior of
all the continents, uh,
still relied on transportation systems,
none of which were superior to a horse.
The cheapest form of
transportation was canal shipping,
uh,
where the motor power was essentially a
horse on a draw path next to the next to
the canal.
And then beginning in the 1820s and
accelerating decade after decade,
uh,
into the 1860s,
the railroad took over
for the first time ever.
One could move freight vastly faster
than a horse and vastly cheaper than any
previous, uh, means of transportation. The
cities grew up initially at the
intersection of ocean shipping,
coast-wide shipping and canals,
and they grew up because there was always
an economic advantage to being at the
junction point between the
main systems of transportation.
Rail took this and
raised it by many powers.
The American rail network.
This is a simplified map.
Rand McNally from 1944 and
it's about passenger rail,
but the,
and the,
the real density of the u s rail network
is about five times what this suggests.
But that density created exactly
what Adam Smith contemplated,
a gigantic market where the division of
labor could be refined to a much higher
level than ever before.
Yeah.
One result of that.
This is a contemporary map of greater
New York and the coloring is dollars of
earned income per square mile and the
densest places right around in here,
uh, reached past 10 billion,
such dollars per square mile.
And the great cities of the
world are invariably once today,
which enjoy powerful rail transportation,
generally sub supplemented
by water transportation,
but rail and New New York's extraordinary
extraordinary advantage as an a
gateway to the interior of
the United States by water,
first up through the Hudson and then
across the Erie canal to the Great Lakes.
And then beginning with
the 1840 [inaudible], uh,
a fabulous deep water harbor for shipments
to the rest of the world connected by
rail, uh, to the entire continent.
The double challenge faced by railroads.
Two things.
One, they were very expensive
to build. So finance,
finance,
capital,
raising large amounts of money in order
to construct railways was one challenge.
And in some senses, and even greater
challenge was actually running a railroad.
It turns out that railroads
get an inordinately
complicated after they get big,
when they are one section
of about 40 or 50 miles.
Railroads are actually not
very complicated things to run,
but when they get to be hundreds
or even thousands of miles,
the logistics of management
get extremely challenging.
So you have two challenges. One is
finance, the other is operations.
And let's start with operations.
Uh, in the 19th century,
train collisions occurred at,
at,
at rates varying from about 400 to
a thousand a year in the u s uh,
and they were often ugly and they
reflected the challenge of management.
Uh, this is a simple one
section rail that operated, uh,
in the 1840s and fifties between
Boston and Worcester, Massachusetts.
Almost all the railroads
built just one track.
And the question was,
how do you run trains back and
forth between these two cities, uh,
without collisions?
And the solution it's in Chandler that
these people had was to instruct the,
the engineers of the trains beginning
at the two end cities to proceed to
Framingham and one turns
and each take a right turn,
so to speak.
Uh,
and sit there until the other train is
in view after the other train is in view
and stopped, proceed to the neck,
proceed to the, the end of your journey.
Pretty simple management. And that
railroad had only about 50 employees.
It was, you know, four trips a
day. And a very simple thing,
but characteristic of capitalism is
that people are not content with small
success and they therefore try to string
together many short railroads on the
theory that average cost will decline
as scale of operation increases.
The New York central system,
which was the glitziest of
all the railways at its peak,
it's peak coming,
uh,
roughly from the period of world
war one to the end of World War Two.
Uh,
this railroad was created
by splicing together,
uh,
dozens of little railroads.
The Mohawk and Hudson ran
between Schenectady and
Albany and it was the kernel
from which this was formed. Uh, the,
it's one, one, uh,
aggregation after another and the
construction of that marvelous terminal in
Midtown Manhattan,
which we're all familiar with.
And ultimately after the thing,
uh,
reaches the end of its end
of its competitive lifecycle.
And The New York central railroad was
essentially at the end of its competitive
lifecycle by the 1950s and
it was there because what,
what, what was hard on railroads?
What was hard on passenger railroads?
Long haul passenger railroads.
This is a soft pitch guys. Yes.
Highway system and on and on freight.
What was the big competitor?
Uh, overland. Okay.
So the interstate highway system with
tracking and ultimately deregulated
tracking, which was
much more efficient. Uh,
the competitive position
of railroads seemed, uh,
to be terminal and the Pennsylvania
railroad and the New York central were
combined in a bankruptcy proceeding in
1968 to form the Penn central system,
uh, which, uh,
soon went bankrupt and it went bankrupt
because the two managements hated each
other and each did as little as
possible to help the other succeed.
The, and this idea of a
mortal life cycle of the,
of the corporation is a one
which comes up again and again.
A week from today we'll do
the Polaroid corporation,
which begins as a brilliant,
innovative firm and ends up
playing defense against other,
more brilliant, more innovative
firms. Uh, only, uh, uh, uh,
a generation and a half after it began.
So what really happens
with railroads when you,
if you don't know how to run up and the
early railroads, nobody knew how to run,
was that as the railroad
scope or scale got larger,
average costs actually went up.
And the reason they went up was that you
had to build a mammoth bureaucracy to
run the thing.
Uh,
the Pennsylvania railroad
got to 50,000 employees fast.
And the challenge of how to
organize that large workforce,
uh,
became severe.
The first cut was spatial,
the without the kind of surveillance and,
uh,
information technology we have today.
They had the telegraph fairly
early on and that's all they had.
And the,
the control over a massive network.
This is the New York central system,
uh,
meant that they cut the system into
sections and created a set of authorities
within each such section.
The ones I've drawn here in
red [inaudible] illustrative.
Okay.
Uh,
then there was a division of function.
There were people who
worried about railroad cars.
There were people who worried about track.
There were people who dealt with
passengers, others with freight, finance,
cost accounting,
human resources and so on.
So you have all these functional stripes.
All this is Chandler. I'm just
simplifying what he says. Uh,
these functional stripes.
And then you've got the geographic
sections and the question becomes,
what do you do with the intersections?
And the chief? My, no,
my comments didn't survive.
I had amusing comments in which I
thought there were amusing in which known
personalities, creative problems. And the,
the fundamental
administrative question was,
do you let the functional groups,
Boston geographic groups around or do
you let the geographic groups boss the
functional groups around?
And what ended up happening was,
okay,
this pattern,
which ultimately gives priority
to the geographic groups,
it creates enormous power at the top in
general management and the top people in
an American railroad. We're
very well compensated, uh,
often, uh, took on ownership stakes. Uh,
and we're true big shots.
The functional people
operated as staff to them.
The people who did accounting,
the people who did finance,
the people who did construction
maintenance, rolling stock and so on.
And then there were a several
tiers of specific managers,
superintendent with responsibility
for geographic areas.
And they too had functionally divided
staff people to worry about the rolling
stock, the track, the
construction, et cetera.
And the pivotal,
pivotal decision makers were always
the people with a geographic focus.
They were the ones who had
to take all the factors,
all the functions together
and make the thing work.
They became the first general managers
of the modern description that Mbas are
training for.
Jeez.
Essentially the origin of the managerial
managerially operated joint stock
corporation. The Europeans
used a different, um,
a different pattern,
which gave priority to the functions.
And by and large, uh, the
American system worked better.
Now, why are European trains so much
better than American trains today?
Anybody know what's here?
Socialist.
Okay. Yeah. Socialism is part of it. Uh,
w please elaborate too.
Let's get from one word to Tim.
We've got Mike.
Uh,
people seem to be more comfortable,
good bourbon a project.
Okay. And this is particularly true
of Cottonelle Europe, I think, uh,
where the trains have become, uh, in many,
not quite all cases, uh,
publicly operated, uh,
systems. There's another reason.
There's a historical reason.
The gasoline price of gasoline,
that's another point.
I hadn't actually connected the dots.
Gasoline there is roughly two
or three times what it is here.
So passenger train for short and
middle sized runs makes a lot of sense.
Big historical event.
Yes.
The Internet
say again, like they
didn't have highways. Okay.
I think, well, some of them did. I mean
the German Autobahn was pretty impressive.
Um, even if the Nazis built it,
it was pretty good highway. The,
um,
what I'm fishing for here is World War II.
World War II destroyed the European rail
system and because it was destroyed and
because of the u s Marshall Fund, which
paid for an awful lot of reconstruction,
uh, they started more or less from
scratch and made the thing work.
And we had this higgledy piggledy remnant
of a previous period and never really
made the investment
by socialism or capitalism.
The challenge of finance
was, uh, equally important.
Perhaps more important historically,
a project that involved a
high capital investment.
We're funded locally,
people made investments within
small circles within one city,
uh,
within the people who live next to it.
The zone where people living next to a
canal or a segment of a canal would in
effect buy bonds and finance the thing.
Railroads were catastrophic,
really expensive.
They sucked up vast amounts of capital.
And so a device
as in the, this bridge, the EADS bridge
in St Louis, over the Mississippi,
there were hundreds,
even thousands of terrifically expensive
construction projects to be financed.
And the mechanism chosen was
the joint stock corporation.
And the forms of,
uh,
of funding took were of two main kinds.
I'm going to get to
some detail in a minute.
One were railroad bonds where people in
effect loaned money to the railroads and
achieved a,
a predictable income,
relatively predictable income
from that investment in debt.
The other was the joint stock queer you
bought into the equity of the company
and became a partial owner.
So world railroad grid.
And I'd like you to just in passing
notice the very uneven density of it.
And the fairly strong
correlation between the density,
the railroad grid and
the wealth of the place.
The railroads were both cause and effect
of capitalist development where the
railroads, there was capitalist
development where capitalist development,
railroads and colonialism had artifact
Africa's railway system got developed,
not so much to create internal markets
as to get goods quickly and efficiently
out for shipment to uh,
the uh,
metropolitan power,
which uh,
which controlled the colonization.
Okay. No, a chart, the dreaded chart.
And here we've,
we have on the vertical dimension
three major forms of ownership.
Indeed, these are the three most
important forms of ownership.
Proprietorship means outright ownership.
You just own it.
End of story.
Partnership means what it
says and interestingly,
and for reasons you'll probably figure
out by the end of the hour if you don't
know it already,
partnerships tend to be used
in a certain kind of company.
And it's a company where the value of the
firm consists largely in the talent of
its employees.
So that the big consulting firms,
the big investment banks,
uh,
the big law firms all take the form
of partnerships and that they are,
and that actually changes at one of
the HBS cases you're getting is the one
where Goldman Sachs ceases to be a
partnership and becomes a company.
Uh, and of course third,
the joint stock corporation.
Then we look at each of
these, uh, with the five,
uh, considerations across
the top in mind. One is how,
what's the accountability chain here?
How do we keep people doing their job?
How do we see the difference between a
job well done in a job poorly done? Uh,
the second is the role of ownership
and uh,
the third is liability.
Every one of these is a huge
factor in understanding this. Uh,
the fourth is liquidity.
If I own something or a part of something,
how easy is it for me to
sell out? Uh, and finally,
scalability,
to what extent can we start with something
small and grow something enormous?
And the three forms,
very importantly in each of
these five dimensions and I,
I'm afraid I'm going to
walk you through them.
The chain of a chain of accountability
and a proprietorship is pretty simple.
I own it, I run it. I'm the boss.
I hire and fire the employees.
I make the business decisions.
I don't submit plans to anyone else.
I just do it.
And in a very small enterprise that
has its advantages in a partnership,
things are more complicated.
The trouble with a partnership is this,
every partner has a right
to participate in management
and I can't,
I can't admit a new partner without
the consent of the other partners.
Now the workaround for this is the,
the hybrid form,
which creates a general partner who
runs it and then a bunch of limited
investment partners who participate
passively and lots and lots of things take
that, that hybrid form. But the
pure partnership is very awkward.
You've got to talk to
everybody all the time.
It's like being married to a
room full of people at once.
What a nightmare.
Uh,
the corporation, the chain of
accountability is very different.
And
it looks like this.
You've got investors over here,
you've got capital
markets with brokerages,
a stock exchanges and such. Like, uh,
then you've got a board of directors,
then top management,
then layers of other management,
and then layer upon layer
of regular employees.
And the chain of accountability
is the white line.
And I've made this one a little
crooked because it is a little crooked.
Have you, how many of you own
stock in a specific company? Not.
Okay.
Can,
can we get a mic down to this gentleman
here with the olive colored shirt please?
Uh,
is it a publicly traded company?
Name it please.
Pardon?
Okay. And, uh, you take an active
role in running the company.
Uh, do you like everything
that management does?
Yeah.
Uh,
why don't you fix it then?
Okay. And, and if you
called up the CEO and said,
I don't like what you're doing, how do
you imagine the conversation would run?
We'd be short. And what
would his suggestion? He is
not in decent suggestion.
Pardon?
Okay.
Pound sand or sell the damn stock.
You don't like it,
get out right and the characteristically
week control that investors have here
puts enormous important
on the exit option.
Indeed,
the exit option becomes dominant
and in day trading for example,
what people are doing is owning
companies for very short periods,
owning tiny slices of companies for
very short periods and exercising.
No influence or accountability,
but just I don't like it.
I'm gone or the,
I believe the price is going to fall.
I'll short the stock and get out so that
what you've created here is a brilliant
device for scooping up small amounts of
investment from a large amount of people,
a large number of people.
So that with the joint stock
corporation you can have thousands,
tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of investors.
They don't know each other. They don't
talk to each other. By and large,
only the large institutional investors
track the company's behavior with any
care.
The specific fundamentals of the
company and the the distancing.
Think about proprietorship where the,
where the boss is in the
shop and partnership,
where the owners are the
partners who actually do it.
We've come a long way from that with
the joint stock corporation and it's an
extremely efficient device
for raising money in that way.
The internal operation on the other
hand is complex and you've got market
mechanisms of exchange outside the firm,
but inside the firm you've
got to manage people,
you've got to incent them,
motivate them to do what needs doing
for the firm and the board of directors
plays a symbolically central role in all
this because they pick top management
and top management is accountable to them,
at least in theory.
And if you think about the recent
crisis in American capitalism,
a lot of it has to do with the fact
that boards have failed sometimes
catastrophic Lee to exercise any real
accountability on top management.
The characteristic problem,
which I've mentioned to you a couple
of times about the firm is so called
principal agency.
I hire you to do something and
you go off and do it or not.
For example, let's suppose I
run something as simple as a bar
and I hire you.
I'm not there in the evening and I hired
you to run the bar and I give you an an
an hourly wage and I
let you keep your tips,
uh,
what might occur to you as a way to
maximize your income at my expense
free. Who set it? Free
drinks or the very deep poor,
right? You order a scotch,
I pour you a double.
You Save the five bucks and
give me two of them. Uh,
and the characteristic of the
situation is that you have,
what's your advantage over
me in scamming me this way?
You keep the tips, but how do you
manage to get away with it? If you,
if you called me up and said I'm going
to do this, I'd say you're fired.
Right? But you get away
with it. Why I'm not there.
You have the eyes and ears
on the scene and I don't.
So you're the agent, you have
a, this is so called asymmetry,
you know a lot more than I
do about what you're doing.
And so the characteristic problem for
four people trying to manage inside the
box inside the firm is to keep others
for whom they are for whose achievements
or malfeasance. They're accountable
to keep them motivated and honest.
The role of ownership,
the sole proprietor runs the
thing simple as that partnership.
They are all there except if
you have the general partner.
But in general the partners say in
a law firm they are all involved.
They will typically create an an an
executive committee and maybe a managing
partner, but pushed to Shovin
and disagreement about the firm.
They are all part of management and you
make them that because they are your
assets. In a good law firm, the
real assets are the lawyers.
Okay?
In the corporation,
the ownership role is,
as we saw a few minutes ago,
strongly attenuated.
Now in actual,
in actual fact,
there are cases where a stockholder's
rise up against management and uh,
throw managed, throw the board
out and with a new board,
throw the management out.
It does happen.
It's just rare.
And it's rare because
the transaction costs,
just the time and effort required to
organize the shareholders is quite extreme
stocks. This is a, uh,
1998 tabulation of the percentage
of us households by income strata,
uh, high, higher in yellow
and lowest in green,
uh,
who directly or indirectly
own among our own companies.
And the,
the just is just what you
would think it would be.
You have a majority of people with six
figure incomes and you've got to inflate
a little bit here from 1998 to now.
Um,
people with relatively high incomes,
uh,
are predominantly,
owners of companies and
the rate of ownership,
uh, scales down with income, which
makes quite a lot of intuitive sense,
but most of the stock is
held in very small parcels.
And the putting together of,
uh,
forget a majority putting
together enough to be noticed,
which begins at about five, 5%, uh,
is a major task
liability with a proprietorship.
If you do a harm to someone
else, a tort, as lawyers say,
if you sell someone a
contaminated bottle of,
of drinking water,
uh,
they can sue you without limit.
If you're proprietorship is worth
$100,000 and you've also got a home where
$300,000 and savings worth another
hundred thousand dollars to make half a
million dollars,
they can go after all of that.
There is no protection against lawsuits
in the proprietorship form with
partnerships.
Things are as bad or worse.
Let's suppose Tim here and
I are partners and Tim,
uh,
for reasons known only to himself creates
a catastrophic train wreck on the line
between new haven and New York one
day and does it in the name of our
proprietorship.
Maybe we're in the business of something
for trains and I'm on vacation in
Europe and Tim calls me up and says,
we've killed 110 people.
Uh, things are really
only the bleak my problem.
Then of course, I'm sorry for Tim, I'm
sorry that Tim will suffer from this,
but I'm even sorry or about me because
the principle of joint and several
liability applies to partnerships so
that the litigant can choose among the
partners and go after
all the deepest pockets.
And that is a,
that is a really major,
a flaw in the ownership structure design
from the individual point of view.
The most striking single thing about the
joint stock corporation is that it has
limited liability
and the
by limited liability we mean if you own
a hundred shares and they have a value
of $7 a piece,
there's $700 worth of capital.
The most you can lose is that
$700 no matter what the firm does,
the firm could blow up the Atlantic coast
and your liability would be limited to
the $700 which would be in effect.
You can lose all of your investment,
but you can't do worse.
Now that's a hell of a deal.
That's an enormously attractive deal and
if you think about the purpose of the
joint stock corporation,
it's easy to understand.
It's easy to understand because we
want people to make investments over
something they can't control and
can't really see inside very clearly.
Now we will,
I'll ask you before the terms over to
have a look at a quarterly filing by a
company. So you get to see
about what investors can see.
But if you can't control it and have no,
no very powerful surveillance
over its behavior,
you wouldn't want to invest in it unless
you are granted relief from liability.
And that's exactly the design.
And there was a hundred years ago,
a race to the bottom among the American
states in how generously they treat
corporations under the law.
And the reigning champion among American
States for corporate law is Delaware,
Delaware corporations abound everywhere
and in particular in places that aren't
Delaware or even close,
because these provisions are tightest
from the corporate point of view,
uh, liquidity proprietorships
are hard to sell.
Um,
in fact,
often it's impossible to really get the
value out of them when you sell them
outside the family.
Um,
and often in fact with say retailing,
the value of the firm is substantially
the goodwill toward the owner that
customers have.
And when the owner sells
it to somebody else, uh,
the value may go to zero.
Although I was just, uh,
I had a boat in a marina on Lake Champlain
for a long time and I've got tireder
and Tireder of the
management of the Marina,
lazy grasping,
unreliable.
And I was talking to somebody on the
phone yesterday and they said, you know,
there are new owners up
there and I thought his Ah,
I may take my boat back.
The,
the proprietorship is a
very delicate creature.
The partnership is worse.
Let's suppose that all of us
are the partners of Wiggin
and Dana Law firm in new
haven where all partners,
uh,
except Morgan here.
And Morgan is a brilliant student
just finishing the Yale law school.
And I'm his advocate. So I say, Morgan,
I'm going to make you a partner.
What do I have to do to make that happen?
In theory,
there are ways to shortcut this,
but in theory I have to get
the consent of all of you.
And so the,
and then suppose I say I'm
tired and old and I want out.
I'm going to sell Jim
Alexander my partnership
and Jim Alexander is generous enough to
offer me a large sum of money for that
partnership.
Okay.
Can I just send all of you a memo
about Jim now being a partner? No,
you've all got to a proven
and the illiquidity of the
partnership as a result is
notorious.
The corporation is designed for liquidity.
You don't even ever have to see
the physical stock certificates.
They are just electronic bit.
The time it takes to sell,
uh,
to shell securities is that,
and the transaction costs are extremely
low compared to the other two.
Now, scalability, can we
make this thing big or not?
And the answer here is in data.
Uh,
these are,
can you read this from the back?
Um, there are about 18 million
proprietorships in the country,
a million and a third partnerships,
5 million corporations.
And their average gross revenue
per year are these numbers.
So the
standard story of a proprietorship
is the dry cleaner on the corner.
Who makes $1,000 a week
and feels good about it.
These are actually gross revenues,
not net.
So what that means is that the
actual take home may be pretty small.
Uh, and the ratios are
suggestive of scalability.
The joint stock corporation
is made to get big and
there are several subtypes of corporation,
but probably the most profound
threshold for corporations is the public
offering,
the initial public offering.
When you take a firm
from private to public,
that is when you, for example, an s
corporation is a very private kind.
You can only have 75 shareholders.
You get some tax breaks,
but you can't market your
shares to a wide public. Uh,
and when you go public, um, Jim,
you've been through that going public
with a company, is that right? Yeah.
Is there a mic for Jim?
What's the process?
This is a spinnaker exploration
by hers
is they call up,
uh, you, uh,
you eventually choose a group of people
that you feel comfortable with and
you convert. Our analysts think
that you have good prospects
draw up a prospectus,
which is a
legal document describing sensibly
ascribing to the investors the principal
risks and the potential
returns of the investment.
You make sure that you have a,
what's viewed as a lawyer, uh, uh,
helping you with that reputation.
You are making sure that you have a
audited financials by a firm reputation.
And then eventually when
the time is writing,
you go around the country for several
weeks talking to perspective institutional
investors,
retail investors in most retail
firms won't buy the smart money,
which is deemed to be institutional,
is not fine. And uh, typically,
uh, typically, uh, you end up with a, uh,
a group,
a situation where maybe 20 to 40%
of your company is solved the IPO,
new money coming in, which typically
face down in bed and you end up with
sort of two to 500 shareholders
have to keep happy at least for the
first year or else bad things happen.
Thanks.
So
the gigantic corporation
is the most productive,
not the most creative necessarily,
but the most productive
player in the economy.
And as you can see here,
nearly 90% of all the business done
in the American economy has done by
corporations.
So that the,
the, an analysis of American
capitalism or world capitalism,
which neglects the joint
stock corporation, uh,
neglect the most important player.
So we will be focused on those ones
like the Pennsylvania railroad here,
uh,
as we go forward.